Các công ty thì đi lỗi bói bói mấy
Nen qua
Côi đã chứng điện hộ gành tâm vô bông bói gặp
Và điều bân trọng trở nân lảo nó xa ơi
Bộ nhống người gặp nhỏ gặp gặp gặp lại nó nơi dây
Nhưng mà trò đô trong gì phổ chứ xin nhỏ
Cô gặp lại là điều bân phổ xe đăng thơm
Là bân phổ nông người gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp gặp
Bây bói có nhiều khi đi ra đi
Nó người này lại lấy nó ra làm công cô để gũi đoạn
Cái này nó bỏ bỏ bỏ bỏ nè trực xa
Hãy có tríng cho những người xu quen
Vyng là mình trở lên qua đến phòng mình
Đăng chế ra làm cho phòng kiểu như thế này
Điều có thể trong những lần trong một xa ơi
Chỉ quen việc hôm gặp nghe trong hòa quốc
Sao mình vánh tính mà xu lý như các lỗi đợi này để làm hôm
Không phải như thế này ngàn con gặp như thế này
Thế bộ xe đea